אופטימיזציה קלאסית היא שלב קריטי באלגוריתמים קוונטיים-קלאסיים
כמו ה-variational quantum eigensolver או למידת מכונה קוונטית.
אבל לרוב מסתבר שקשה למזער
פונקציות מורכבות במרחבי פרמטרים רב-ממדיים.
שמי Victoria Lipinska ובסרטון הזה נחקור
שגרות אופטימיזציה קלאסיות לאלגוריתמים קוונטיים-קלאסיים.
בעיות אופטימיזציה הן לא פשוטות.
ככל שמספר הפרמטרים גדל, כך גדל גם מספר הצירופים האפשריים
של ערכים, והגידול הוא אקספוננציאלי.
בשח-מט, למשל, יש 64 משבצות
וכל שחקן מתחיל עם 16 כלים. אחרי שכל שחקן מזיז כלי אחד,
יש 400 מצבים שונים. אחרי שתי מהלכים 72,084 מצבים,
בערך 9 מיליון אחרי שלושה ובערך
280 מיליארד אחרי ארבעה מהלכים.
אם נגיע רק ל-40 מהלכים, מספר המצבים האפשריים
מוערך בסביבות עשר בחזקת 120.
לשחק משחק מושלם היה מחייב לבחון את כל המצבים האפשריים
והגידול העצום הזה אומר שלעבור על
כל המצבים בנפרד זה לא ישים.
אפשר לפתור את זה על ידי פיצול הבעיה לשתי תת-בעיות קטנות יותר.
ראשית, צריך לקבוע אילו תצורות של לוח השח
עשויות להופיע בשלבים עתידיים של המשחק שלנו.
נקרא לזה תת-המרחב שמעניין אותנו.
ושנית, בהינתן אותו תת-מרחב, צריך לקבוע מהי המהלך הטוב ביותר.
נקרא לזה המהלך הטוב ביותר שלנו.
באנלוגיה הזו, החיפוש הראשוני בתוך תת-המרחב שמעניין אותנו
הוא האנלוג של אלגוריתם האופטימיזציה הקלאסי שלנו.
ברגע שתת-המרחב שמעניין אותנו ידוע,
אלגוריתם קוונטי אחראי בדרך כלל למצוא את המהלך הטוב ביותר,
בהינתן אותו תת-מרחב.
נתחיל בכך שנשקול פרמטר אחד בלבד,
theta, שמפרמטר פונקציית עלות שאנחנו רוצים לאופטמז.
אם נצייר את הפונקציה, נניח שהיא נראית בערך ככה,
על ציר ה-X יש לנו ערכים של הפרמטר theta
ועל ציר ה-Y נמצאת פונקציית העלות.
כדאי לזכור שפונקציית העלות יכולה להיות עלות כספית ממשית
שאנחנו רוצים למזער, או כמו שקורה לרוב ב-variational quantum
eigensolver, יכולה להיות אנרגיה שהטבע ממזער.
המטרה שלנו היא למצוא את ה-theta
שמתאים לעלות הנמוכה ביותר.
מתחילים עם ערך התחלתי של theta ובכל שלב אופטימיזציה
מוצאים theta חדש שמקטין עוד יותר את העלות.
נדמה שאנחנו יודעים די בקלות לאן להתקדם בגרף אם אנחנו יכולים לראות אותו.
אבל הקושי באופטימיזציה הוא שבעצם אנחנו לא יכולים.
אנחנו רק מגלים את העלות, חתיכה קטנה מהפאזל הגדול,
ברגע שאנחנו מחשבים את הפונקציה על ה-theta שנבחר.
זוהי הדרך הכללית שבה אופטימיזציה עובדת.
האופטימייזר דוגם פרמטרים theta ומחשב את העלות.
כפי שאפשר לדמיין, בחירה אקראית של הפרמטר theta כדי לשחזר
את הטופולוגיה כולה של הפונקציה היא לא יעילה במיוחד.
במקום זאת, מה שאופטימייזרים חכמים עושים הוא למצוא
את הגרדיאנט של הפונקציה בכל שלב.
כך האופטימייזר יודע לאיזה כיוון בגרף
להמשיך כדי למצוא את העלות הנמוכה ביותר.
ברגע שהגרדיאנט הוא אפס, האלגוריתם מסתיים,
והמינימום נמצא.
המינימום הזה לא בהכרח הוא המינימום הגלובלי.
יכול להיות שזה מינימום לוקלי,
כלומר זה הערך הנמוך ביותר של פונקציית העלות בסביבה הקרובה
אבל לא על כל טווח ה-theta.
במקרה של פרמטר אחד, זה בהחלט אפשרי.
אבל ככל שיש לנו יותר פרמטרים,
הפונקציה הופכת מורכבת יותר.
כבר במקרה של שני פרמטרים, יש לנו משטח,
ובמקרה של ארבעה, אנחנו כבר לא יכולים לצייר את זה בכלל.
בדיוק כמו בדוגמת השח-מט, שחזור כל האפשרויות
הופך במהרה ללא אפשרי.
אנחנו רואים שקשה למזער
פונקציות מורכבות במרחבי פרמטרים רב-ממדיים.
אבל כדי לקבל תוצאות סבירות, אנחנו רוצים שאופטימיזציה קלאסית
תהיה גם מהירה וגם מדויקת.
הן גם צריכות להיות עמידות לרעש,
שיהיה לו השפעה משמעותית במחשבים קוונטיים בטווח הקרוב.
אלגוריתמי אופטימיזציה קלאסיים ניתן לחלק באופן כללי
לשתי קטגוריות - חיפוש ישיר ושיטות מבוססות גרדיאנט.
שיטות מבוססות גרדיאנט דורשות מידע על הגרדיאנט
של הפונקציה במהלך תהליך האופטימיזציה.
אפשר לחשב את זה אנליטית
או לקרב אותו בחישוב הפרשים סופיים.
שיטות חיפוש ישיר לא משתמשות במידע על הגרדיאנט
ומשתמשות באסטרטגיות אחרות כדי למזער את פונקציית העלות.
חלק מאלגוריתמי האופטימיזציה הנפוצים ביותר
בנוף המחשוב הקוונטי הם האופטימייזרים הבאים.
COBYLA מייצג אופטימיזציה עם אילוצים על ידי קירוב לינארי
והוא אלגוריתם אופטימיזציה ללא גרדיאנט.
SLSQP הוא תכנות ריבועי-לינארי רציף לפי שיטת הריבועים הפחותים,
אלגוריתם אופטימיזציה מבוסס גרדיאנט.
הוא משתמש בוקטור הפרעה סטוכסטי
כדי לחשב בו-זמנית גרדיאנט משוער של פונקציית העלות.
בסביבה ללא רעש, אופטימייזרים כמו COBYLA
ו-SLSQP נמצאו כמתכנסים מהר יותר מ-SPSA.
לאופטימייזרים קלאסיים יש פרמטרים משלהם
שאפשר לציין למקרים ספציפיים, למשל, גודל הצעד.
אלה ניתן למצוא בדרך כלל בתיעוד הקשור
לאופטימייזר הספציפי.
אני ממליצה לבדוק את רשימת המקורות למטה להשוואה
של האופטימייזרים הקלאסיים העדכניים ביותר.
בואו נחקור עוד תופעה אחת שקשורה
לאופטימיזציה קלאסית של circuit קוונטיים עם פרמטרים.
כפי שראינו קודם, גרדיאנט שנעלם של פונקציית העלות יכול להצביע
על כך שהאופטימייזר הגיע לרמה שטוחה ללא תכונות מעניינות, מה שנקרא
"barren plateau."
barren plateau יכול להיות תוצאה של גורמים רבים.
הגרדיאנט של פונקציית העלות המתאימה ל-circuit קוונטי
עם פרמטרים שאותחלו באקראי
דועך אקספוננציאלית לאפס עם מספר ה-qubit.
זה מפני שהמרחב הקוונטי שהאופטימייזר חוקר
הופך גדול באופן אקספוננציאלי כשמספר ה-qubit גדל.
הדרכים להתמודד עם הבעיה הזו כוללות צמצום מספר הפרמטרים
ולכן את הממד של המרחב הבסיסי.
דרך נוספת לחשוב על מקור בעיית ה-barren plateau
יכולה להיות האופי האגנוסטי לבעיה של ה-circuit עם הפרמטרים
שמתמודד עם מרחב פרמטרים גדול אקספוננציאלית.
עיצוב circuit בצורה שמותאמת לבעיה הנדונה
יכול להיות פתרון טוב.
מעבר למרחב הפרמטרים האקספוננציאלי שגורם ל-barren plateaus,
תופעות פיזיקליות אחרות יכולות גם הן לייצר אותם:
הרעש והדקוהרנציה הקיימים בניסויי המחשוב הקוונטי,
יכולת הביטוי הכללית של ה-circuit עם הפרמטרים,
או אי-לוקליות ומידת ההסתבכות של פונקציית העלות שמדוגמלת.
זה נשאר תחום מחקר פעיל לטיפול באתגרים האלה.
לאחר שסקרנו את הרכיבים העיקריים של VQE,
נסכם את האלגוריתם בסרטון הבא.